every slap in this movie is is
completely real and entirely serious and
not unpaid fulness pop stick comedy and
just friends to talking about strange
new technology during our interview for
the proposal we Twitter everybody
Twitter's right yeah I'm twittering
right now I improved in the early days
of his career that he knew how to make
us laugh are you a romantic guy like you
do plans did your mom call you and ask
you what you do for Valentine's Day time
that would be creepy so no I don't hear
from my mom on Valentine's Day although
I do love her it's not we're just
friends okay but even though the
vancouver born hottie was perfect
rom-com material there were a few signs
he had his sights set on something a
little more super i heard it one of your
next roles that you would like to try
out is a superhero maybe i don't know i
mean it's it's been talked about for a
couple different roles but you know it's
kind of finding the right one and maybe
one day i'll i'll do it but it's gonna
have to be sometime in the next five
years some getting old
in 2011 ryan wouldn't be too old to jump
into his first lead role as a superhero
in green lantern a separated shoulder to
operations are you still as keen to do
your own stunts um you know I'm just I'm
realizing though that I'm you know 34
years old falling on cement used to be
hilarious no now it just feels like
cement even more painful than all those
stunts was the fact film didn't meet box
office expectations
for trouble but on the plus side he did
me to suit your wife Blake Lively onset
of the superhero flick what's it like
not only to boss him around but to get
to kiss him as well you realize how many
jealous women there are out there right
now if they knew him better they
wouldn't be so jealous but something
must have charmed Blake because a few
years later they were expecting their
first child and I found myself giving
Ryan parenting tips backstage at the
2014 Canada's Walk of Fame gala so when
your child is congested you stick this
up their nose and you give it a gentle
suck like a and this will bring out the
snot and this is important because you
need to can I train the dog to do this
no the next two years of Ryan's career
were a little quieter starring in
low-budget films like Mississippi grind
the captive and the voices but it was
Ryan's next stab at the superhero genre
in 2016 that would cement his eggless
status I am very turned on right now
Deadpool earn 783 million worldwide
while its people took in over 785
million why does the world love Deadpool
it lives up to the hype
plus plus he's a guy that occupies his
face in this cinematic universe that
almost no one else can occupy is a
direct relationship to his audience he's
emotional
he's a little immature at times he's
outlandish he says the things that we
might be thinking but never say I didn't
say why did I love Ryan rental no since
then the highly respected actors been
working with a listers like Jake
Gyllenhaal in the movie life we can't
let that thing in here Matt Babel
Entertainment Tonight Canada thank you
I'm your father and in 2017 he teamed up
with samuel l.jackson in the hit man's
bodyguard thank god you're here
I don't know what I would've done
without listen Sam Jackson asks you to
say mother say mother just do it
okay mother come on right I'm so late I
just feel American right now and Ryan's
now regularly selling out theaters his
latest blockbuster Pokemon detective
Pikachu raked in over four hundred and
thirty million worldwide we're big fans
obviously of yours and we can't wait for
the movie and we all have [ __ ] won so
you want to have this nice cuz my own
whoa that's a weird one
isn't it like your face on that right
that's super weird how to scare children
in five seconds I got to you by et
Canada
you